good morning Hank it's Friday Pizza Miss
rolls on today's video comes to you in
four very special parts Part One the
weirdest thing that ever happened to me
so obviously a lot of weird things have
happened to me over the years but I
think the weirdest one is Cheesa John
this thing is amazing it's a terracotta
planter so you can either like spread
chia seeds around here and make my hair
into into Chia or you can use it as a
regular planter just put some potting
soil in there and mint basil anything I
think I'm going to plant a mint plant in
there so when people come over I can
offer them a mint Jep and be like I have
fresh mint it comes out of my head it's
just the most wonderful thing sorry both
of our glasses fell off and it's
available only during pizz Miss and only
at pizz miss.com along with this
incredibly soft blanket all right part
two hard left turn so one thing about
pizza missan is that you're allowed to
make dramatic tonal shifts like here's a
video of me at the UN here's what the UN
is here's my face as a planter so I'm
going to take a hard left turn right now
Hank and tell you the truth of what I've
been feeling feeling for the last few
days which is extremely grateful that
you're doing so well like it is
incredible to see you dancing on many
levels but one of them is just that it's
wonderful I'm just so relieved and happy
that at least for the foreseeable future
you are through chemo and doing so well
like it's just wondrous and a little
discombobulating because 5 months ago we
were on the phone being like should we
cancel pizz Miss like we'd already
ordered some of the stuff and so we
couldn't cancel it but at the same time
we were like maybe we we have to cancel
it and now you're dancing and you have a
surprisingly thick mustache and I just I
want to tell you how I feel about that
which is really grateful I don't want to
be overly sentimental but it's it's nice
it's really nice part three but speaking
of the mustache Hank I think everybody
in our family has some concerns about
the mustache not its presence during
Pizza Miss but the way you've hinted
that it might become a more permanent
presence in our lives and I feel like I
need need to express in the strongest
possible terms Hank that your pizz Miss
mustache should only be a pizz Miss
mustache and to support this position I
I'd like to introduce two exhibits into
evidence exhibit a you look like the
minneapolis-based rapper Prof except
soft you know profk the rapper who
memorably wrote so drunk that I can
hardly see is that Jennifer Aniston
balancing on a manate now you're both
obviously excellent lyricists but Prof
can pull off the mustache because he's
hard and you're
respectfully soft exhibit B and it gives
me no pleasure to do this but I would
also like to enter into evidence the
great goatee debacle of 2011 given how
poorly this aged how can we be confident
that a post pamus mustache wouldn't age
equally poorly it has to end with pamus
Hank Okay part four hard left turn again
pizz Miss always reminds me of the
distance between my current self and my
2007 self self like how did my 2007 self
make videos every other weekday for a
year what must have my priorities been
like how much free time must I have had
my life was just very different then
when I was in my teens and 20s I kind of
thought that human life was like a
bullet train that rocketed you through
all these spectacular environs before
arriving at the end of the train line
which was called adulthood and then you
got off the train and just stood there
in the station until death came for you
it turns out of course this is not true
like adulthood is really interesting and
full of change I changed a lot in my
teens and 20s but I also have changed a
ton in adulthood including since
starting this project 2007 we had no
idea what it was like to have kids or to
live in the same town for 17 years or to
be part of an online community that
convinced a multinational multi-billion
dollar Corporation not to make money off
its tuberculosis tests in poor countries
but I also couldn't know all the
terrible and hard things we were going
to go through I couldn't know that you
were going to get cancer or the other
difficult things we've been through so
yeah in kind of a lovely way I feel very
distant from my 2007 self and it makes
me wonder what does my 2039 self know
that current me doesn't amazing things
I'm sure and and also terrible ones as
Octavia Butler put it the only lasting
truth is change Hank I'll see you on
Monday